la vaccination contre la copie de 19 par
votre médecin c'est désormais possible
depuis aujourd'hui une quantité de doses
limites et a été livré hier chez les
pharmaciens
ce sont eux qui gèrent la logistique et
la conservation en lien avec la rs pour
le moment un flacon par semaine par
praticien l'équivalent de dix vaccins
reportage chez un généraliste à
saint-cyr-sur-loire hélène chapelet
trois patients ont reçu ce jeudi matin
la première dose du vaccin astrazeneca
dans ce cabinet médical de saint cyr sur
loire
parmi eux guillaume 56 ans ce professeur
d'histoire géo souffre de problèmes
ventilatoire et cardiaques
considéré comme un patient à risque il
s'est lui même confiné depuis la fin du
mois d'octobre
aujourd'hui grâce au vaccin il espère
pouvoir de nouveau exercer dans son
collège de chateaurenaud et retrouver
une vie plus apaisée avec ses proches
c'est pas dans le rôle du tout petit
chaleur c'est tout le rencontre que je
suis comme un poids si vous voulez pour
pour eux au nid à gérer donc le plus
vite possible je devais me faire
vacciner pour qu'on puisse retrouver des
relations normales et puis qui se
sentent moins moins stressés vu mon état
et puis l'intérêt pour moi aussi c'est
de retrouver rapidement mes élèves et
mes collègues retourner au travail
deuxième patient de la matinée nicolas
55 ans il y a huit ans il a fait un
infarctus ce qui le place dans la
population à risque lui aussi estime que
les effets secondaires de ce vaccin ne
sont rien au regard de la liberté qu'il
va retrouver une fois les deux
injections faites perdre et je suis
entrepreneur associé gérant et je n'ai
pas du tout envie d'avoir la
problématique du duc au vide pas si moi
je suis arrêté passé tout mon activité
qui est arrêté donc je voulais pas
prendre ce risque donc évidemment je
trouve ça normal et en plus par rapport
je dirais à la protection même de la
globalité de la population je suis
persuadé que le vaccin c'est ce qu'il ya
de mieux ce vaccin astrazeneca s'adresse
aux personnes de 50 à 64 ans présentant
des risques de comorbidité en
indre-et-loire 330 généralistes se sont
portés volontaires pour l'administrer
soit 68 % des médecins qui exercent en
cabinet pour les patients de 65 à 75 ans
pour l'instant rien n'est encore prévu
espérons que soit ce vaccin là et le et
quand même l'indication pour les 65 75
ans ou qui a un autre vaccin qui arrive
donc il ya il semble qu'ils aient
d'autres vaccins qui arrive le spoutnik
2 russes et puis éventuellement il ya un
johnson & johnson aussi américains les
trois patients du jour qui ont reçu
leurs premières doses ont d'ores et déjà
rendez vous dans six semaines pour la
seconde injection
super génial